[Musique]
et donc le service de santé des armées
va travailler à développer a fait montre
de grands centres de vaccination puis ça
fait vaccinodromes ont des gars centre
quelques soit de quel que soit le nom il
ya au moins 35 centres qui vont être
déployés à la fois par l'armée des
pompiers sur le territoire national et
nous en déployant avec l'état
l'assurance maladie un certain nombre
d'autres aussi pour pouvoir être capable
justement d'utiliser tous les vaccins
qui nous sont livrés à partir du mois
d'avril pour vacciner massivement des
phrases
[Musique]
on fait le choix de vacciner d'abord les
personnes âgées très fragile chez elles
dans leur lieu de résidence dans les
ehpad les soignants dans leur maison que
sont les hôpitaux et des centres de
vaccination à destination de la ville on
va beaucoup s'appuyer sur la médecine de
ville et nous voulons avoir la
vaccination de proximité
et lorsque vous ne parliez tout à
l'heure de la relation avec les élus
j'ai déjà demandé aux élus d'identifier
des structures dans lesquelles nous
pourrions travailler avec eux pour y
rassembler des médecins des infirmières
je ne suis pas du tout certain que ça
doivent prendre c'est mon opinion
la forme de grands stades dans lesquels
viendrait faire la queue des milliers de
personnes en plein hiver